A
INGRAHAM IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
♪
>> HELLO, I AM LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
POPULAR AMERICAN PRESIDENTS
MANAGED TO CAPTURE THE SPIRIT OF
THE TIMES.
IT WAS FINALLY AFTER JIMMY
CARTER MORNING IN AMERICA.
AND AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF BUSH,
OBAMA GOT AN ELECTORATE WITH
HOPE AND CHANGE, BUT WITH JOE
BIDEN AND HIS TEAM, THE
OPPOSITE.
>> WE ARE STILL FACING DARK
LIMITS.
>> HERE'S THE SITUATION.
WHEN IT COMES TO GAS PRICES,
GOING THROUGH AN INCREDIBLE
TRANSITION, GOD WILLING WHEN
IT'S OVER WE WILL BE STRONGER.
>> IT IS NOT LIKELY TO BRING
DOWN GAS ANYTIME SOON.
>> WE WON'T HAVE BLOCKBUSTER
REPORTS, BUT THAT IS A GOOD
THING.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A GOOD THING.
AND REMEMBER RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES ARE ALSO GOOD BECAUSE IT
MEANS THAT MORE OF YOU ARE GOING
TO BE FORCED TO TAKE OUT A LOAN
TO BUY SOME ELECTRIC CAR THAT
YOU CAN AFFORD AND YOU DON'T
WANT.
AND IT'S ALSO A GOOD THING AND
NOW THEY ARE HAPPY BECAUSE THEY
ARE STEERING THAT INTO OUR
DIRECTIONS WHEN THEY ARE BEING
ATTACKED ON A DAILY BASIS BY
MARXIST EDUCATORS AND LEFT-WING
ACTIVISTS.
SAYING ONLY MANY SAY IT'S ONLY
FAIR AND THAT IS NEGATIVE 32 ON
THE CONFIDENCE INDEX.
EVEN WORSE, 77% AND THAT
INCLUDES WHAT IS GOING ON NOW.
>> WHO IS CALLING, WHO IS
TEXTING, WHO IS E-MAILING, DOING
THOSE THINGS DURING THOSE 187
MINUTES.
>> YES, THAT IS ALL THEY HAVE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JANUARY 6, WHITE SUPREMACY, A
RUN ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
AND UNLESS HEIGHT BY THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE PRESS WHO ARE A
BIG PRIMETIME EXTRAVAGANZA THAT
BEGINS NEXT WEEK.
>> WE ARE CLOSING IN ON THE
BLOCKBUSTER PUBLIC HEARINGS, THE
FIRST OF THE YEAR, SAYING THAT
THIS WILL BLOW THE ROOF OFF THE
CAPITAL.
>> IT IS OFFICIAL THAT THE
PUBLIC HEARINGS ARE BEGINNING
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT.
>> THIS IS ALL A SHOW IN EVENT
AND LIKE ANY GOOD THING THEY
MUST PLAY THEIR ROLE.
DISTRACTION AND DEHUMANIZATION.
>> THAT IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL
WITH SOME OF THE NOISE AND WE
KNOW THEY WILL BE COMPETING.
>> I'M GLAD WE HAVE THAT ON
CAMERA.
>> SO WHAT ARE PEOPLE UP AGAINST
IN THE DAY-TO-DAY LIVES THAT
THEY ARE LIVING?
>> NEEDING MEDICAL GRADE
FORMULA, RISKING PERMANENT BRAIN
DAMAGE, THE SHORTAGE IS
OBVIOUSLY, IT IS LIFE ALTERING.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO IN TWO
WEEKS IF HE DOESN'T GET THE
FORMULA THAT HE NEEDS.
>> HE HAS CALLED ME AND SAID
THEY CAN'T GET IT.
IT'S NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
SO IT'S NOT DONE BEING MADE YET.
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING.
FROM ALL ACCOUNTS, NEW SHIPMENTS
OF BABY FORMULA ARE WEEKS AWAY,
NOT DAYS, BUT WEEKS AWAY.
THEY HAVE NO HOPE LEFT TO OFFER.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS TEAM REFUSE TO
CHANGE COURSE BECAUSE THEY LIKE
THE COURSE THAT WE ARE ON.
DECLINE IS THEIR PLAN.
THEY WANT YOU TO GIVE UP ON THE
PROMISE OF AMERICA AND ACCEPT
THAT FAILURE IS INEVITABLE BUT
THIS WILL NOT WORK.
IT WON'T WORK WITH JOE BIDEN.
AMERICA IS STILL THE LAND OF
POSSIBILITY AND WE ARE NOT GOI